hello everyone and welcome today's live
webinar exosomes and super resolution
microscopy presented by dr. ryan
mcnamara i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by o n I to learn more about our
sponsor please visit them at WWN i/o now
let's get started today's webinar is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or use act ask a
question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain those credits I now present
today's speaker dr. Ryan McNamara a
research associate at the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill dr.
McNamara's research focuses on multiple
facets of aids progression from cellular
infections with HIV - how can concurrent
concurrent infections and/or
malignancies affect HIV pathogenesis
through investigations into these
processes we can increase our knowledge
of basic cellular biology as well as
identify pathways amenable to targeted
therapies dr. McNamara welcome you may
begin your presentation
thank you very much Suzy and thank you
all for being here for those watching
this live welcome and for those watching
this at a later date we will this is an
interactive session and you can always
ask me questions both now and at a later
date and we'll get back to that at the
end of the presentation so the title of
my talk is exosomes and super resolution
microscopy and a little bit of
background about how I got into this
field of exosomes is that I am actually
a biologist and my background is
studying numerous infectious diseases
and here are just a few of them on the
left you have West Nile virus this is a
flavivirus this is an RNA virus and
under negative staining through electron
microscopy it yields is very beautiful
icosahedron particle next to it is
herpes virus which we will go into a lot
throughout the remainder of this talk
herpes virus also has a capsid but it is
surrounded by this very large cell
acquired membrane unlike West Nile virus
herpes viruses genomes are DNA
and you can really think of an exosome
as a virus without a capsid so exosomes
transfer nucleic acids from one cell to
the next they have this very meta or
very malleable cell acquired membrane
that can be taken from the endosome in
the case of exosomes or from the plasma
membrane in the case of micro vesicles
and also like viruses they transport
cargo from one cell to the next
so exosomes and their study presents a
few caveats that we're going to be going
through in this really the topic of this
talk but just a little bit of a one down
of a nexus ohm they typically have a
hydrodynamic diameter of about 30 to 200
nanometers although this can vary a
little bit based off of the preparation
method and their size is estimated to be
about thirty to a hundred and twenty
nanometers and this is an electron
microscope image that I took with a
collaborator Lindsay Costantini all
right North Carolina State University
and the diameter of these guys that
you're seeing here about 60 to 70
nanometers
now that diameter is below the
achievable resolution of conventional
light microscopy
we will get into that a little bit later
on so as far as the biogenesis of an
exosome and exosome is a unique
extracellular vesicle and that it
originates from inside of the cell and
it originates from this body called the
multi vesicular body the multi
particular body is a cluster of inwardly
imaginated endosomes which traffic's to
the plasma membrane and releases these
exosomes
as a cluster other cell of other cell
release extracellular vesicles can
include micro vesicles which directly
but off at the plasma membrane very
similar to how HIV is secreted and
another large class of a politic bodies
which are released when a cell is
undergoing apoptosis extra zones are
unique to these other classes of
exercise are vesicles in that they
originate from inside of the cell so
just to recap exosomes
originated from the early endosome
they merge into the multi vesicular body
through the inward imagination of those
early endosomes and they are secreted as
a cluster
here what you're seeing is a these are
cells that stainle Express a CD 63 which
is a marker of an early endosome tag
with key height pH Euler and what you
can see is that these guys they light up
and what I really want you to focus on
here is that they are predominantly
localized inside of the cell although
you do see some eventually going towards
the plasma membrane these are the
endosomes which become exosomes that are
secreted from the cell
so how do we see an X's Oh
exosomes present a number of problems
for their study through visualization
they present a very large problem and
that they are actually below the limit
of resolution of white light so over on
the left you will see a rough schematic
of a nexus and the first thing that
you're probably going to notice is that
their diameter is less than 150
nanometers
they typically range anywhere from 40 to
120 nanometers in diameter and they in
inside of an exosome are proteins
nucleic acids such as micro rnas and
other non-coding rnas and you they are
uniquely marked on their surface by
proteins called tetris spanning these
tetris bannon's
can include CD 63 CD 81 CD 9 BD 45 and a
few others and we're going to go over
those tetris bannon's a lot throughout
this talk and again I got into this
field because an exosome has biophysical
characteristics that are almost
indistinguishable from viruses there is
a similar size there of a similar
density and their role appears to be in
the transfer of materials from one cell
to the next
so on this slide I'm going to show you
all a short video of nanoparticle
tracking and how we can visualize
exosomes through this method
okay so what you're seeing here is a
nano particle tracking analysis of the
exosomes
that we isolated using our isolation
technique what this is is dynamic light
scattering in which a laser is pointed
up into the exosomes and diffracting
light and those wobbling stark shaped
objects are the exosomes and how quickly
they wobble can give us information on
their size
okay so what we can visualize through
nano particle tracking analysis are
really three independent attributes
about the particles viewed and that is
their size distribution so for example
here's a size distribution analysis
using a nano particle tracking analysis
in which you can see that exosomes have
a point narrow peak as far as size
distribution other exerciser vessels
such as microvesicles typically are a
little bit larger as our a pop tonic
bodies and B jab and BC be l1 these are
just two different cell lines that we
frequently employ and this just to show
you that regardless of source the
exosomes
appear to be of the same diameter from
the nano particle tracking analysis you
also get neat and load sizes through the
Brownian motion and lastly you can also
get concentration measurements
so the purpose or one of my goals is to
develop a tractable system for exosomes
to monitor functional consequence and
I'm going to propose doing this through
three independent steps one is a robust
isolation pipeline in which we can
isolate a concentrated preparation of
homogeneous and functional exosomes so
for example here is a preparation of
exosomes viewed by negative staining
electron microscopy the second step is
to produce a tractable system to follow
delivered exosomes and that is
to identify which cells and organs can
uptake the s adults and where they
traffic
and this can then be viewed via super
resolution microscopy
you
and the last step is to have a
functional readout and this is very
important for us biologists is to have a
no response by recipient cells to exit
ohms so that we can ask dizzy delivered
exosomes retain functionality and so
what I'm showing over here are cells
treated with HD exosomes HD just answer
a healthy donor and exosomes
taken from kshv this is Kaposi sarcoma
herpes virus this is the cells infected
with kshv taking the exosomes from them
and delivering them to recipient cells
and asking do we have a unique phenotype
so to go over a robust isolation
pipeline how we isolate X is ohms is
through cross-flow filtration and we
couple that with a high molecular weight
from photography and this allows us to
isolate exosomes
from liters of input solution so really
briefly to go over cross-flow filtration
what you have is an input fluid that is
put into your cross flow chamber there
in pink through peristaltic pump it is
pumped ultimately into across a
molecular weight cutoff filter things
larger than the molecular weight cut off
filter ultimately returned to the cross
flow chamber things that are smaller
than the molecular weight cut off are
lost to the permeate and this occurs
over the course of several hours and it
you it allows you to concentrate your
solution in our case exosomes while
simultaneously equilibrating them with
an equilibration buffer
once we have our concentrated solution
we put these through a high molecular
weight chromatography system we prefer
to use cap decor and what you can see is
that we people to isolate a discrete
pool we call this our extracellular
vesicle peel that has high acetylcholine
esterase activity a high concentration
of particles per mil and also a very
unique and identifiable protein band as
judged by silver stain
when you mount these onto grids and
measure them manually via electron
microscopy when you use captive or when
use cross flow filtration followed by a
tactic or step we're able to get a very
nice homogeneous peak of exosomes and
this is that difference to other methods
such as ultracentrifugation which really
puts a lot of physical stress on the
exosomes
and can lead to slightly larger shifts
in sizes
so the next step that we wanted to do is
develop a tractable system to follow
delivered exosomes
so we'll briefly going back to what is
an exosome exosomes are marked on their
surface by these tetris Fannin's CD 63
CD 81 and CD 9 and we can take advantage
of that to couple those Pro those
proteins to fluorescent transgene such
as GFP and M chair so what you're
looking at here is a super resolution
image of a cell Co expressing CD 63 gfp
and cat1
in chair and I'm going to zoom in on a
small box highlighted there in yellow on
the far right on our merge panel and
what you're going to see is a very
beautiful overlay most of the time of
these two proteins what you're looking
at here are most likely late endosomes
or multi particular body clusters of
these proteins so this is looking at the
maturing exosome inside of the cell via
super resolution microscopy
beebee 63 and CD 81 are part of the same
complex the exosome or in this case the
late endosome for multi particular body
and just as a control we want to overlay
CD 81 with actin via super resolution
microscopy and just ensure that what we
are having is a nice overlay that we can
do functions or that we can do
statistics on and as you can see when we
zoom in there in yellow and other box I
highlighted on the far right you can see
that we have a nice beautiful actin
filament there in this case the actin is
stained with phalloidin 488 I'm sorry
Alexa for 488 and what you can see is
that CD 81 and cherry does not really
co-localize with actin filaments
so that's inside the cell outside of the
cell we typically like to isolate
exosomes
using antibody coated beads in this case
this is another super resolution image
of exosomes conjugated to an antibody
coated bead in this case anti cdat one
and these are exomes from our cells that
produce CD 63 gfp and CD 81 m cherry in
blue is CD 63 we false-color these just
for our for the colorblind audience we
don't want to do any red-green overlays
here so we false colored CD 63 in volute
CD 81 is there in red and this is what
we typically see on antibody coated
beats and that is that the exosome tend
to cluster onto these beats however
times you get really lucky and you can
identify what appears to be a single
exosome on a beat and through a
collaboration that we heard that we are
working on with the University of North
Carolina Department of astronomy we are
trying to model images such as this to
identify could this be a single X ISM
and since TV 63 and CD 81 when the cells
surface what we can do is we can
essentially draw a sphere around the
perimeter in which only the fluorescence
intensity is around the perimeter of
this sphere and in this case that sphere
the diameter is about 82 nanometers in
solution and this is the expected size
of an X's own so this is a very tricky
setup for super resolution microscopy a
lot of people prefer photo switching for
for such as alexa floors we chose to do
this using conjugated proteins because
we wanted to be able to see exactly with
very discreet definition where our
signal was coming from and if possible
could we actually do something like this
where we are looking only at the
perimeter of of a nexus
Foundation method instead of this
approach in which you're using
conjugated proteins and this is most
likely a much easier method to do is an
indirect labeling of the exosomes using
antibodies in this case you can have an
anti CD 63 conjugated to an Alexa for
555 or an anti CD 81 conjugated to an
Alexa for 647 and you can do both of
these at the same time and when you do
that you typically see something like
this and what you're able to really see
the entire definition of an X is ohm so
here in orange is CD 63 CD 81 is colored
in blue and when you draw a straight
line through the image and again this is
through super resolution microscopy you
can see that these two tetris patents
are sitting upon an X's ohm and
oftentimes in very close proximity
towards each other and if you're very
talented at this procedure then you'll
be able to draw essentially the entire
perimeter of a cell or the entire
perimeter of an X's ohm and measure the
diameter from one end to the next and
this is done with Alexa for conjugated
antibodies which allows for more
definition as you can see there's more
signal particularly on that image to the
right you can see that there's a lot of
events there and this is a distinct
advantage to using Alexa for conjugated
antibodies as opposed to direct
conjugation of CD 63 or CD 81 with
fluorescent proteins
so going back to our system we have our
CD 81 conjugated to an M cherry so if we
have a cell pellet in annexes own pellet
we would expect that n cherry to be
carried over into our exosome pellet and
so here is just a protein block showing
markers of annexes ohm that our tetris
bannon's
part of the escort machinery this is the
endosomal recycling complex as well as
hotel and to which they live in raft
groups and as you can see those proteins
are enriched in our exosome pellet
whereas beta-actin is enriched primarily
in our cell pellet the sources for these
are either wild type or cdat 1m cherry
expressing cells now when we isolate the
XSL pellet from these cells what you can
see is at the end zone pellet from our
CD 81m cherry expressing cells is
vividly red whereas the exosome pellets
from our wild-type cells is mostly
opaque kind of gives a almost a
yellowish you
so the next step after isolation is that
we want to know could can these exes
ohms beat up taken by cells in this case
what we did is we incubated primary poor
for a woman mononuclear cells or PBMCs
with exosomes taken either from our
wild-type cells or from our CD one CD 81
in cherry cells as a positive control we
have our wild-type exosomes labeled with
an organic dye dii this artificially
turned the exosomes red and as you can
see here via via flow cytometry we are
able to transfer these CD 81 and cherry
exosomes into our primary cells
we next wanted to know where these where
these exosomes go so this is a super
resolution image of endothelial cells
treated either with wild-type exosomes
or exosomes isolated from our CD a e1m
cherry producer cells and so as you can
see in our M cherry channel this is
excited with a 562 nanometer releaser we
do not get any signal above background
however when we treat cells with our CD
81m cherry exosomes you give this very
speckly appearance so zooming in on that
yellow box on the right you can see that
these exosomes
go into these relatively punctate
structures upon bringing them in by an
endothelial cell
now it can be odd to this approach is
that this is actually looking at CD 81
in Cherry we cannot conclude from this
image that the exosomes themselves are
intact this may very well be unloaded
protein from the delivered exosomes
notwithstanding what we have shown is
that you can deliver labeled exosomes
either with an organic dye such as dii
or directly conjugated such as CD 81m
cherry echoes ohms and see them via
super resolution microscopy
so the last thing that we want is to
have a functional readout and this is
very important to us as psychologists
so well the emerging picture of exosomes
is at a climb in environment they are
very they act very local to maintain
local homeostasis and it has been shown
that a number of viruses have usurped
this pathway to incorporate factors into
X's ohms factors such as micro rna's or
Myra lien coated protein in the case of
Kaposi sarcoma herpes virus or kshv kshv
is able to incorporate a number of micro
RNAs into exosomes
and we wanted to know if these kshv
exosomes were capable of exerting a
unique phenotype on recipient cells so
what we did is we treated endothelial
cells which are the target of
transformation by kshv with exosomes
isolated either from control cells or
from kshv infected cells and these are
affinity purified so that we are not
actually adding on any infectious virus
onto these cells we are only interested
in what happens when we add exosomes
onto these cells
we did a chronic exposure to up we did a
chronic exposure of Emil endothelial
cells with these exosomes and we took
out RNA for RNA seek at different time
points we did this experiment all the
way up to 12 days and we divided this up
into the time points of acute
intermediate and chronic
and what you're seeing here is an RNA
see of significantly altered genes a
cells treated either with control
exosomes or kshv exosomes we identified
somewhere around 300 significantly
altered genes
that's where the result aquatic treat
with exosomes taken from kshv infected
cells
so that's on the nucleic acid and
transcriptional side what about just the
physiological side but your endothelial
cells view through H&E staining that
were treated either with lock with
control lysosomes with kshv exosomes
or just looking at endothelial cells
chronically infected with khb and what
you can see in panel C is an enhanced
swarming of the endothelial cells when
exposed to KSHB exosomes
this is further confirmed through
activation of the cell proliferation
marker ki-67 so on top ourselves our
endothelial cells treated with exosomes
from a healthy donor and on the bottom
ourselves treated with exosomes coming
from kshv and what you can see here is
activation of the cell proliferation
marker ki67
so hopefully I've convinced you that we
have developed a tractable system to
view
functional consequence of exosomes
so the remaining questions that we have
that can be greatly facilitated through
super resolution microscopy are what
specific contents of exosomes
contributes to discrete phenotypes so
recall that exosomes
incorporate micro rna's they incorporate
proteins they also incorporate some
other things however an exosome is
beneath the limit of resolution of white
light so therefore identifying factors
inside of a nexus ohm can really only be
done using super resolution microscopy
if you want to be able to tease it apart
from one specific exosome to to the next
so we in our case as biologists we want
to understand what is it about these X's
on that is exerting such a unique data
type such as the swarming of these
endothelial cells
or their transcriptional reprogramming
another remaining question that we have
is how our uptaken contents sorted so
this is the endothelial cell treated
with exosomes that are expressing or
that have CD 81m cherry on their surface
as you can see the exosomes go into
fairly discrete punctate structures or
at least the CD 81m cherry dust
we're not sure this is still an intact
exosome or if this is protein being
unloaded we also do not know what these
specific compartments are
and through the use of super resolution
microscopy we're able to get down to
nanometer based resolution to identify
what these compartments are is this the
lysosome
is this the late endosome is at the Auto
phagosome those answers are very for
those are very difficult questions to
answer through conventional microscopy
and that is something that super
resolution microscopy can really
facilitate our learning
another remaining question is actually
going back to the production of exosomes
so this is our cell these are our
producer cells which express CD 63 gfp
and CD 81 m cherry and as you can see
i'm zooming in on that little square on
the right and hopefully what you can see
is that while CD 63 gfp and CD 81 m
cherry do have several regions where
they call localized CD 81 m cherry tends
to have a little bit more globular
cluster e and this can actually be
quantitated over here on the left as a
frequency as a clustering and frequency
analysis as well as you can see see dat
one has more cluster links bt 63 tends
to being a little bit more discrete
localizations this is also confirmed by
just viewing endogenous CD 63
and see dat one as well when you look at
either see dat one em cherry or in gaja
see dat one you see see dat one going
into more of these cluster lured domains
where a CD 63 tends to be a little bit
more discreet although they do overlap
like treat
also we also kind of want to understand
the tracking of exosomes
in recipient cells so what you're seeing
there hoping yes what you're seeing
there are these little guys going into a
cell
now we're not entirely sure if the
exosome is up taken as a whole or if it
fuses with the plasma membrane
different groups have different
perspectives on this and I don't really
want to get too much into that but this
is another thing the super resolution
can really facilitate our understanding
is not only how our exosomes taken up
but where are their contents traffic to
and how are their cost and how are their
contacts contents recycled through the
recipient cell
and from that previous slide that I
showed you you can actually view how
these things are up taken and this is a
diffusion coefficient graph from the
previous from the previous cell that I
showed you in which case the contents
that are going into the cell can be
tracked using super resolution
microscopy and you can really start to
see where these things are go now the
individual compartment we're still
working on that and this is something
that we were actually working with the
only people on this a very is quite a
difficult question to answer but using
super resolution we actually think that
we can ask this is a very answerable
question
with that I'll go ahead and wrap up and
we can start taking questions I want to
thank people at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill particularly
Dirk Denton Washington Anya and Jack
Griffith we have collaborators of the
Tulane National Primate Research Center
for armed attack Studies I also want to
thank dr. Lindsey Costantini at North
Carolina Central University she is my
collaborator for electron microscopy
imaging we also want to thank the good
folks at Oxford nano imaging who were
able to look at our data refine it a
little bit give me some of the
clustering analysis and we're still
working with them and the funding agency
that I'm supported by er the National
Institute of Health as well as the A's
malignancy consortium and with that I
will conclude and thank you all for your
attention and we have a lot of questions
to get to but thank you very much for
hosting
and thank you so much dr. McNamara for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started as
dr. McNamara said we have a lot of
questions already coming in thank you
audience members our first question dr.
McNamara is from which tissue have you
isolated the exosomes
so from which tissue have we isolated
the exosomes we have taken these cell
lines that are maintained in the lab and
these are very common cell lines such as
293 cells
0 cells we take them in our case for
from a garbology perspective we take
them from lymphocytes visa can either be
cultured or primary derived and our
isolation protocol also allows us to
take exosomes from primary fluids such
as plasma such as urine and we've also
even isolated exosome from cerebral
spinal fluid although those lines are
actually quite low the exosomes are rich
in so many so many fluids whether it's
tea to culture or body fluids we stay in
the eukaryotic system and multicellular
organism system there's other
researchers who do this kind of on
ailments and even on bacteria we prefer
to stick in higher eukaryotic systems
thank you and what is the initial volume
required to isolate these numbers of
exosomes and which is the source cells
in culture
okay so
that red pellet the
I showed earlier in the presentation
that was taken from osteosarcoma cells
that were stable expressing CDA t1m
cherry this is actually a clonally
expanded cell that we isolated via flow
sort and the exosome pellet from that
cell or yes home hello from those cells
was taken from a liter of cells and this
is an advantage that we think that we
have to using tangential flow filtration
and cross-flow filtration is that is you
can use industrial scale volumes now
when you're talking about things like
human plasma it's a little bit more of a
dense fluid and we usually don't work
with a ports of a liter of human plasma
we normally work in the range of
something like 40 to 100 milliliters of
human plasma and this is processed by
removing the erythrocytes and the
leukocytes we just want that that plasma
rich layer and you can isolate the
exosomes from that either by tangential
flow or by affinity purification so
things like cerebral spinal fluid you're
only going to get a couple drops of we
typically use antibody coated beats
directly to get those
thank you and dr. McNamara can the cross
blow filtration purification method
avoid the membrane debris with similar
size as exosome during the purification
can cross-flow filtration so I assume
that some of the membrane debris that's
being referred to here might be things
such as
LDLs or HDLs well some kind of other
lipoproteins or maybe even microvesicles
the cross-flow filtration part is really
meant to concentrate down your solution
selecting for large macromolecules so we
have a molecule a cut-off filter a
$750,000 so this is going to remove a
lot of secreted lipid moieties as well
as kind of contaminating dibbley and you
can change the size of the pores on your
cross-flow filtration setup now other
things such as viruses and microvesicles
you cannot this you cannot separate
those through this method using
cross-flow filtration because the
properties of a micro vesicle a virus
and exosome they're very similar as far
as molecular weight and really to tease
apart of those you need an additional
step we use antibody coated beads other
people may often use density gradients
they use sucrose gradients I additional
ingredients there needs to be a
subsequent step in order to really tease
apart those those complexes thank you
for that and our CD 63 CD 9c d 81 and
cd45 ubiquitous markers on the exosome
oh boy you're going to get me in trouble
at answering this one CD 60 these tetris
Fanon's
the current model is that these tetris
spans are on the surface of vesicles
that we term exosomes
okay that view is actually evolving
maybe a little bit I think what some
people may have seen on my super
resolution imaging with that c63 and CD
81 they're not always together
in fact one thing that we have seen and
this is actually been confirmed through
some of our collaborators and some other
some other laboratories throughout the
United States and throughout the world
is that PD 81 and C D 9 can actually
localize to the inner leaflet of the
plasma membrane so in that case if they
butt off straight from there they would
be classified as a micro vesicle
this is again something that we're
really interested in employing
super-resolution for because you can
really get down to the nanometer level
of resolution to see okay where is this
vesicle coming from now as far as being
ubiquitous markers on exosome across
cell types and these Tetris panels do
seem to be fairly will Express across a
number of cell lines across a number of
tissues from the body some tend to be a
little bit more enriched coming from a
certain tissue than another but for the
most part they seem to be present on
these exosomes coming from a number of
different cell types
thank you so much and again thank you
audience members for these great
questions coming in dr. McNamara how to
how do you purify the labels exosome
after labeling the exosome with dealed
dye are you removing floating guy
so that is a great question and we
actually filter out the dye using the
captive coil resin so what we have is
kind of a slurry of exosomes and dye and
this is a great question what you have
is a slurry of exo-m and dye but a lot
of that dye is not incorporated so if
you're going to treat cells with labeled
exosomes you want to be sure that the
ponte structures that you're looking at
are because of the exosomes and not from
unincorporated dye
so we incubate the ester domes in this
case with the d-iii we incubate the
exomes with that and then we passage
that through a tactical call and we use
CAPTA core resin specifically because it
was designed to purify viruses CAPTA
core resin was meant to remove chicken
albumin actually got the going back a
little bit in time it was meant to
remove chicken albumin from from food
production for or vaccinations because
of poultry allergies and the Catholic
Court has a very high molecular weight
cut off I believe that the lonely I
believe it's 700 kilograms and what it
ate what is able to do is really capture
and retain things that are that are not
of that molecular weight cut off and as
you're passing this through your your
column you'll easily be able to see your
exosomes
traveling through this column with the
DI I die and to regenerate the column we
just use sodium hydroxide and what you
see is that the unincorporated die takes
a while to elute off from these columns
so we really do believe that through our
through that protocol we're really only
labeling our exosomes there's an
alternative way of doing this which we
also do and that is adding in the dye
and then doing it antibody bead capture
of the ences ohms so in this case the
exosomes
are immobilized on the beads and excess
dye is just washed away through whatever
wash buffer that you're using so get yes
we are trying very hard to ensure that
unincorporated die is not contaminating
our file prep that's a very good
question
thank you and are these exosomes
expressing labeled CD 81 or CD 63 and
this is a two-part question
if so then how do you assess the
functional readout of WT exosomes on the
recipient cells using the methodology
okay so I'll take that first part are
these X's ohms expressing labeled CD 81
or CD 63 the answer is yes and no and
folk so sometimes is just the CD 81 best
labeled with M cherry sometimes it's
only the CD 63 disabled the GFP and
sometimes we use we use both of them so
we have we have clonally expanded flow
sorted cells that are expressing CD 81 M
cherry C 63 GFP or a combination of the
two
and we kind of set our control using
that system so you know what we're doing
we're dealing with two floor holders
here and GFP and M cherry so that we can
really allow ourselves to do three
colors through storm microscopy we have
on our storm we have a four hundred
nanometer laser a four eighty eight
nanometer laser 562 nanometer laser and
a six forty seven negative answer the GF
key for the CD 63 GFP is going to take
up the 488 the CD 81 m cherry is going
to take up the 562 and that leaves us
with with two more channels and we can
still do super resolution with so the
answer the answer is really all of the
above we want to be sure that we're
doing all of our controls problem so if
so how do you assess the functional
readout of wild-type Nexus on recipient
cells using the methodology so we're
using the CD 81 in Cherry or CD 63 GFP
or the combination to build our system
up the the wild-type exosomes
is really just a comparison in in order
to to ensure that our exosomes
are labeled so moving forward we're
going into the fluorescence system so we
want to be able to track our exes ohms
using the CD 81 and cherry or C 63 GFP
the wild-type exosomes
is really a negative control and we're
not terribly concerned about the
functional readout of a per se just a
wild-type alone because we're labeling
these X's ohms then Nova we're labeling
them inside the cells so that we can
track them and I hope that makes sense
thank you for that please and are the mi
RNA the major cargo and did you check
the mRNA in the exosomes
and actually there's one more part of
this question is the mRNA is it
functional or just
argument without function in the
exosomes
okay all right so we'll take the first
one is the micro RNA the major cargo of
a nexus up not really they do constitute
a large subset of cargo
but micro RNA just fall under the
broader umbrella of de clay acids and
other groups have shown that non-coding
RNAs some mRNAs can get in there some
sno RNAs can be pushed into exosomes
so micro rna's are just one of many
things transferred I via accidents so
did we check the mRNA in the exosome a
little bit we didn't find too much mRNAs
in the exome for our purposes especially
in the biology based approach we were
mostly focused on micro rna's because
they are incorporated into Exum's at
very high rates much higher than mRNAs
so then the final question mrna is a
functional or is it just a short
fragment without function in exosomes
for this question I think the best
example we have
biologist is there there's a group that
is reported that hepatitis C virus can
incorporate the full-length mRNA of
hepatitis C into an exome and transfer
that to a non infected cell and the mRNA
is is functional in that case in our
case we don't really find kshv or other
herpes virus mRNAs in our exosomes
so we don't really have a functional
readout for them because we don't we
don't really detect mRNAs in in our
system but again our system is unique
even to that other system of of
hepatitis C thank you so much and are
there any known receptors of exosome oh
wow that's that I mean that's the
million-dollar question so X is ohms we
think of how I think of them as viruses
without a capsid and viruses are very
specific and what kind of settled that
they infect so HIV for example goes into
T lymphocytes or macrophages via abiding
to cd4 cxcr4 and ccr5 so these are very
receptor dependent uptake of the virus
exosomes appear to be able to be up
taken by just about any cell that that
you isolate whether they're or
lymphocytes endothelial cells
macrophages cardiac cells by hepatic
cells yeah so it is there a receptive
for exosomes
I mean that that's a great question
because if there is a receptor for
episomes it would appear to be fairly
ubiquitously expressed across very
different cells and so in that case that
that's pretty much beyond my realm of
expertise because I'm a little bit more
as of I rolla gist you know I guess when
you're good with a hammer the world
looks like a nail so I look for very
specific receptors of a virus I say yeah
again hepatitis C only goes into liver
cells exosomes can go really anywhere
they want so it is very interesting to
think about I am I do not think that the
field has come to a consensus on
a bona fide exosome receptive yeah that
matt is a very good question and
hopefully that is a good answer because
some people might really disagree with
me on that one
I'm trying to be as safe as possible
thank you so much dr. McNamara and these
are such great questions coming in our
audience is fabulous today is the nano
particle tracking analysis for measuring
size published somewhere and what form
of super resolution my got from my
coffee microscopy I can never say that
word by microscopy what was it used so
is the nano particle tracking analysis
for measuring size published somewhere
the nano particle tracking analysis is
based off of dynamic light scattering
and this has actually been around for
quite a while and it was just what they
were able to do is really bump up the
sensitivity for these things for these
nano particle tracking machines in order
to see exosomes so exosomes
do not really diffract a lot of light so
they're very difficult to see through
other methods such as flow cytometry
other people can see the via flow
cytometry but to do that you have to
have a very specialized flow cytometry
particle tracking has been has been
around for a while and really what it's
doing is just measuring the Brownian
motion of particles and how quickly
they're wobbling around and based off of
how quickly they're wobbling around is
able to to judge the size of a particle
based off its wobbling properties
and the second question is what form of
super resolution microscopy was used in
this talk this was
DeStorm and I understand that
this was and this is a little bit tricky
here so typically people who do DeStorm
this is with six samples and they're
doing this with Alexa fluor or diorite
conjugated antibodies we do these with
directly protein conjugated fluorescent
proteins and we do it also in a
combination so the act and
super-resolution microscopy images that
I was showing that was with phalloidin
conjugated to alexa fluor 488 we do this
with other pollutants such as Alexa for
647 along so for 555 the set up is
fairly similar from from a technical
sampling however the the proteins do not
photo switch as well as Alexa force or
die lights and that is something that
the the people oh and I have really
wanted me to to stress particularly in
this talk and that is viewing GFP and M
Jerry by super-resolution is not this is
not easy
you need to have cells that Express a
lot of these things which is actually
why we did flow sorting we not only
wanted positive cells we wanted belite
positive cells we wanted cell that we're
expressing a ton CD 63 GFP and CD 81 and
cheery we have a couple other cell lines
we also have seating the IM cherry we
wanted those cells to be very bright
just because the physical properties of
em cherry and GFP as far as photo
switching goes for DeStorm they're not
anywhere near as optimal as those as out
of alexa fluor
conjugated antibodies for alexa fluor
conjugated phalloidin so the protocol is
the same mostly but the sensitivity
range is is very different and I would
kind of defer a little bit more on the
biophysics of that to to the only people
who I work with and we have a lot of
conference calls together on how we can
optimize yeah kind of optimize how we're
setting this up because it actually is
quite difficult
thank you and in your experience
what is the best whole exosome labeling
protocol is it a D ID or NHS reactive
dyes in sodium bicarbonate pH and it
says pH 8 buffer yeah so in this case
when you're labeling exosomes
with an organic dye and this question
brings up the DI series of dyes di d-dip
and there's other ones such as the I I
di o we have
and and I've even brainstormed this one
with any people through the nano imager
we do not have a lot of luck with a DI
series of labels do they work yes you
can get them to photo switch
they don't photo switch a lot and you're
not able to get a lot of resolution
you're not able to get some of those
some of those images I was showing
earlier of a single less ism in that
case those were labeled with CD 63 and
CD 81 I think it's yeah it was
it's very difficult to do those with the
di series so talking with Rafael and
Tasha over at over at offer nano imaging
they pointed me towards this series of
dyes called cell masks dyes and the film
f dyes there's just two of them that we
use gel mask green and cell mask red but
some mask red is a small red dye and it
shows up fairly well on our 647
nanometer excitation laser Mesilla map
screen shows up fairly well on the 488
excitation laser again it's it's not the
best your samples will will photo bleach
fairly quickly and you're not going to
get too many photos switching events but
people are people are doing this and
they're doing it and incredibly well
there's a couple groups who who do this
really well we've for the most part
moved away from the DI series of dyes
for super resolution microscopy and we
lose more into the cell mess but even
still and those you're going to have
some problems because they're really
tricky to to work with more protocols
are being developed to to get single
exosome resolution off of the nano
imager the di series just seem to be a
little slow operable
thank you and did you do sucrose
gradient you see the super gradient or
ultra centrifugation is a great way to
kind of cushion your your exosomes that
are being put on an ultra centrifugation
- we prefer to do antibody based
selection of exosomes as opposed to
sucrose based selection of exid ohms
because we really want to ensure that
the viruses and the exosomes are
separate from each other this far is
densities go the density of an X is
element of micro vesicle and a virus are
pretty similar you can't separate them
off a very carefully prepared to grocery
addiction audience but we we prefer not
to risk that we just go straight towards
antibody based capture of X's ohms so
that we can be fairly certain that we're
not contaminating with with viral
particles think
tomorrow and our next audience member
wants to know what do you mean by
hydrodynamic diameter and how does it
influence the exosomes analysis okay so
the hydrodynamic diameter of an X is ohm
kind of a little referring to here is
just what exosomes are in solution so if
you could shrink down to you know 30
nanometers in size and just swim through
out glass but how big do exosomes look
in there in a native state so we when we
mount these for transmission electron
microscopy the protocol that we use
dehydrates them a little bit and because
of that they're going to be shrunk down
in size a little bit more than what they
would be in their in their native state
so that's what I was was trying to get
out and and how is and how does it
influence the the exosome analysis and
that's kind of that's part of one of the
ridges that influences how you analyze
these things is how are they prepared so
if you're looking at these via what term
microscopy our method dehydrate them a
little bit if you're looking at them
through nano particle tracking analysis
they're in solution so they're a little
bit more in their their native and their
happy state but through nano particle
tracking analysis what you're really
looking at is diffracted light you're
looking at scattered light so it's kind
of more of an indirect measurement
because you're using the scattered light
to see how quickly they're wobbling
around and then you calculate their
diameter base also the Brownian motion
of how quickly they're wobbling around
every method of quantifying exosomes and
microvesicles in these other
extracellular vesicles every method has
its own pros and cons and it's just a
matter of doing
whatever you can with the tools
available to you
thank you for that and our next question
is a two-part question is your exosome
isolation protocol similar to tangential
flow filtration and do we need
sophisticated equipment to set up an
isolation protocol in a lab so really
appreciate this question I use the terms
tangential flow filtration and
cross-flow filtration interchangeably
for part for this talk so the answer to
the first part is yes is our protocol
similar to Dan general for filtration it
is because it is tangential for
filtration that L is the first step the
second step that we do is we generally
try to concentrate that down even
through them you can also put it over
chromatography based resins especially
when were labeling them with dyes so yes
tangential flow filtration we use
because we want to start off with
industrial grade volume in our case when
we're getting that the light red Xs on
pellet from our CD 81m cherry producing
cells we're starting like a leader of a
cell of super mate and not many not many
isolation techniques really isolate
something from a leader without a an
initial concentration step and that's
why we do tangential flow so the second
part didn't need sophisticated equipment
to set up the isolation protocol in the
lab well the first thing that you need
is a tangential flow filtration operator
in our case we have a reservoir tank
that can hold up to a liter of input
solution
and then you have to go through okay
what is the best filter and for your
system for us we use a 750 killed Alton
filter I've seen other groups use 300
kilo Dalton filters
I'm sure that there's some other groups
how therapy who play around with via the
filter size on that and you also need to
play around with how much pressure
you're putting on the exes albums your
flow rates I
we do have a manuscript then we
published I think it was in November of
last year that kind of goes into it a
little bit more detailed including the
specific instrument that we're using so
the answer is yes there is a startup
cost for this isolation protocol but it
really allows you to get exosomes to a
very concentrated solution so you can
really perform in vivo experiments at
physiological relevant concentrations of
exosomes
while retaining the function
thank you some
and did you use the nikon buffer to
cause blinking of the GFP and M cherry
okay so for the blinking of GFP and M
cherry is a great question we use the B
cubed solution from Oxford nano image
and we have continued to use this for
years now
I mean we've known och we've known the
only people for years now and we we
weren't sure how well that so how well
that buffer was going to work for our
system
until I believe they came and we demoed
the instrument and as it turns out it
actually works very good especially for
GFP em cherry is a little bit more of a
kind of stickler this will be more
difficult GFP seems the photo switch a
lot better than in Cherry it's difficult
to say if that's a property of the floor
[ __ ] of the of the buffer of the
stability of the protein itself of the
abundance of the protein itself there's
a lot of variable to account for there
but for ours from our purposes the B
cube solution works works very well in
our system for both fluorescent proteins
as well as Alexa folders and the die
lights
thank you so much and I thank you
audience members these are just great
questions coming in today
have you tried to label non Tetris
banning fluorescently to image exosomes
oh so we did label okay so we we have
labeled PSG 101 with an M cherry
we got fairly similar results and that
is with a fluorescent protein but also
importantly we also just look at the
endogenous gene so these we look at
unlabeled CD 63 unlabeled CD 81 and we
do this just with with antibodies and
those antibodies conjugated to to Alexa
folders
the results are fairly similar you see
some things enriched a little bit more
in the cytoplasm in the in the early
endosome you see some things a little
bit more enriched into globular domains
I see Dae one tends to go to a little
bit more globular domains so to stuff
the protein a looks at least in our
hands so the answer is yes we we have
gone back and forth the purpose really
of going into the gfp nvm cherry system
is that we wanted to be able to view the
exosomes from production inside the cell
to purification outside the cell and two
subsequent delivery and to identify what
compartments they're going into and for
our for our research the tetris tannins
seem to work the best although it is
difficult for me to answer them because
we haven't really invested so much time
and energy into looking apps at a lot of
these other genes and we know that a
couple other groups are are actually
doing that right now and they they just
they have a they have more people
working on it than than what we do so
I'm not going to step on their toes
thank you and our exosomes too large to
pass through the ion channels
well it it kinda depends on what kind of
channels it you're talking about here if
if we're talking about neuronal cells
there's a great group at the University
of Chicago that is working on this right
now
and
he's at Northwestern uh his name is
escaping me right now but uh really is a
really good guy I talked about several
meetings and they're really focused on
distinguishing exosomes from these other
things spat out at internal junctions
are they discrete particular bodies do
they originate from from the same
pathway are they up taken in the same
pathway and you know my I just a lot of
that is so preliminary and it is a
little bit more tailored towards did and
neuroscience field that I just I don't
feel very qualified to answer that
question because that is as a very good
question and neuroscientist is and
that's a pretty tough that's a pretty
tough field
thank you so much and our next audience
member says first of all very
interesting talk and he wants to know
how much do you typically get the
exosome particles per liter of cell
culture and what about per ml of plasma
all right great question um
that okay we find typically that the
exosome concentration in plasma is
higher than that problem cell culture
superpaint
so we typically don't need to use as
much plasma as self with your supernate
now when we take it from a leader a cell
culture supering sometimes we even work
with a little bit more we're looking for
a final concentration after all of our
steps we're looking for a final
concentration of about 10 to the 13 to
10 to the 14 particles per milliliter
and our volumes are typically we bring
it down to about I would say about 300
to 500 microliters so yes we're taking
the exosomes from a leader and we're
bringing it down to half of a mil so it
is a very long concentration step this
is through tangential flow followed by
either precipitation with polyethylene
glycol you can also do this with more
affinity capture methods so that is a
total particles per milliliter now not
all those particles are exosomes
you have a lot of other exercise
vesicles that aren't classified as
exosomes so from that solution that we
have about 10 to 13 to 10 to the 14
particles per mil we can do an antibody
capture on magnetic beads or protein a
beads and we typically get somewhere
around I guess it kind of depends on the
source anywhere from 10 to the 10 to 10
to the 11 we're almost always saturating
our beads at that point so it's hard to
get a concentration much higher than
that specifically of exosomes the
as we're doing an antibody mediated
capture Andalucian but that is a that's
that's a great question and it does kind
of show that there's a big difference
between worthless cell culture and
movement plasma that another primary
fluids that the primary fluid you have X
isms in your plasma that originated from
cardiomyocytes you have them originating
from endothelial cells from lymphocytes
from nephrotic cells but from all sorts
of cells just being dumped into your
plasma whereas in the cell culture
setting you can Lee only have a clonal
cell line that is spinning on exosomes
so it really is two different different
environments and one is just going to
vastly outnumber the other in terms of
concentration
thank you so much and dr. McNamara how
do you loot the exosome if you're using
if using an antibody coding bead so we
loot them with acidic glycine it's been
shown that Exum's are actually pretty
resistant to to low pH and so we allude
this to kind of based off of a typical
immuno precipitation method in which you
incubate your immobilized exosomes
on the antibody coated because you
incubate them with acidic glycine we add
a little bit of a heat about 37 degrees
and then we do a quick buffer exchange
to neutralize the acid so that we're
able to ensure that we're not having
exosomes just permanently bathed in acid
and hopefully that that makes sense
time for a couple more questions are you
able to change the filter cutoff to
isolate other subpopulations of v's
I mean that's a really good question and
I can't say that
we've really looked into that too much
we we intentionally have a very high
molecular weight cutoff filter so that
we're only capturing things like
exosomes like microvesicles like viruses
we use the same method to isolate
viruses from one you know other other
things like LDLs and h and and hdls
particularly from plasma they seem to be
able to bypass that filter as well so we
might even be able to use a higher
cutoff filter if you wanted to really
separate out your exosomes and your
viruses from those other guys now via
tangential flow is it possible to
separate extra zones from microvesicles
and viruses not really because they're
so similar as far as their diameter as
far as their molecular weights that
other subsequent steps need to be
utilized to really obtain discreet
populations
thank you dr. McNamara we're going to
answer three more questions I just want
to remind audience members that any
questions not answered during our
presentation will be answered via email
so don't worry your questions will be
answered
have you thought about labeling the XML
RNA and CD 81 for colonization
monitoring inside recipient cells have
we thought about labeling the RNA I'm
sorry if the XO some'll RNA and cdat one
for colocalization monitoring inside
recipient cells oh boy I like that
question and okay so this is really
looking at the endocytosis part of this
so if CDA e 1 is trafficked out to the
plasma membrane as part of the multi
vesicular body to release excess ohms is
it also trafficked kind of to the to the
other membrane to receive exosomes and
that's kind of I mean that's that's
something that we're we haven't even
been able to get into that that one yet
and that's a really good question and
that's something that again the nano
imagers is going to be really good for
because you're going to be able to tease
apart
exosomes as opposed to I would say like
endosome compartment as opposed to the
lysosome as opposed to the the Auto
phagosome
things are pretty difficult to
differentiate based on confocal
microscopy and other conventional light
microscopy methods because you really
want to be able to get some
compartmentalization of the endosomal
recycling pathway and that I mean that's
a really good question we we I
personally have not done that and that
there's a very ambitious thing to do
thank you for that and can exosomes
transfer from plasma to : urine bladder
or other parts of gastrointestinal
system
so can the exosome transfer from the
plasma to the colon to other parts of
the GI system I mean that is it's kind
of I guess it's kind of a difficult
question to answer so when when things
are in plasma the first cells or the
fill that they're going to see in plasma
are going to be your lymphocyte
population other circulating cells as
well as the endothelial cells which line
the vasculature so I guess that the
question is can the exosomes transverse
that entire area
Bertrand transverse the the endothelial
cell and vein barrier and get into the
Coleman and in some of those other cells
I don't know I mean if a cell is not
somehow connected to the vasculature
annexes ohm might have a difficult time
getting into it now there's been some
other model in biology particularly out
in the laboratory of student group in
which he's as proposed that viruses like
HIV can be up taken like in exosome just
go through the endosomal recycling
pathway and exit that same cell I don't
know if I've ever been looked in to for
exosomes
but exosomes behave oftentimes very
similar viruses so I do think that's a
very good question and something to for
the field to look forward or somewhere
for the field to look into as we move
forward thank you so much and this is
our final question today and again don't
worry your questions will be answered
via email what's your opinion if virus
isolation from exosome is more
beneficial than virus isolation directly
from plasma or not
in virus isolation from exosomes would
beneficial and virus isolation directly
from last month so I'm guessing is it
more beneficial to take things from a
guest cell culture or from plasma I
guess
and particularly in the case of virus
and exit homes
um
do things from plasma and in vivo system
is always going to be as close to the
whole environment as you're going to get
so when you're in a cell culture system
things are fairly artificial and fairly
controlled taking it directly from
plasma and it's much more than vivo
system health that also complicate
things because if you take exosomes
for more viruses from plasma you don't
really know where they came from in
enviros is a little bit easier to track
because have a tie this virus is going
to come from your liver is going to come
from your compat asite exosomes taken
from plasma is very difficult to
backtrack where they came people are
looking into that and this goes back to
a previous question about the tetris
famines
being on the surface of exosome and are
they are they ubiquitous some cells seem
to have them enriched a little bit more
than others and there's a whole bunch of
other proteins incorporated into
exosomes that seem to have similar
traits you know backtracking that is and
that's very it's very difficult so if
there's pros and cons right because you
have it in your vivo system taking it
from plasma you say okay this is a
really good snapshot of what we have
going around in circulation but I
find where they came from and really
where they're going is pretty tough in
the cell culture system you're saying
okay if we have a culture of T cells
what kind of exosomes do they secrete
can we say okay here is the the the
marking of an exome from a T cell is it
unique enough from a separate culture
that is of B cells can you really
distinguish them and that and and that
question can only really be answered in
coral populations of cultured cells I
think but these one has our own pros and
cons and I can't say I have a strong
feeling on either because it really
depends on the question that you're
asking
dr. McNamara thank you so much for your
time today and clearly your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor oh and I for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go I want to remind the
audience for thank you for joining us
today and for your amazingly interesting
questions again just a reminder that
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via contact information you provided a
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to and share
this email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now and we hope to see you again
soon
have a great day bye bye